power over the world should be shown, this
is exactly what the so-called
West put at stake in its game, but the
game is definitely dangerous
bloody, I would say dirty, it
denies the sovereignty of countries and peoples, their
originality and uniqueness do not put
the interests of other states in anything
you know, I have always believed and believe in this power of
common sense, therefore I am convinced sooner or
later that the new center of a multipolar
world order and the West will have to start an
equal conversation about the common future for us
, at the same time, simplification, the erasure of
all and any differences have become almost the
essence of the modern,
what is behind this  simplification First of
all, this is the disappearance of the creative
potential of the West itself and the desire to
restrain blocking the free development of
other civilizations will quote from the
famous Harvard speech of Alexander
Savich Solzhenitsyn back in 1978, he
noted that the West is characterized by a
continuing dazzle of superiority,
which further supports the
the assumption that all vast areas
on our planet should develop and
develop to the current Western systems
78 years Yes, nothing has changed Russia,
being an independent original
civilization, has never considered and does not
consider itself an enemy of the West
Americano Phobia Anglophobia Francophobia
Germanophobia these are the same forms of racism
as Russophobia and  anti-Semitism, however, as
well as any manifestations of xenophobia. But if the
other West is aggressive, cosmopolitan,
non-colonial speakers As a tool of the
neoliberals,
Russia, of course, will
never come to terms with the dictates of this West.
criticism In the address of our opponents, any is
perceived as the machinations of the Kremlin, the hand of the
Kremlin is some kind of nonsense, yes What slipped
Well, at least move your brains somehow more
interestingly state your
point of view somehow
conceptually specifically on unification on the
financial and technological  In the midst of monopoly, the
erasing of all sorts of differences
was built, and the Western model of globalization was
not about Colonial in its essence, the task
was understandable to strengthen the unconditional
dominance of the West in the world economy,
and for this to put natural and financial resources at its service,
intellectual Personnel and
economic opportunities of the entire
planet  called the new
global interdependence But as soon as
non-Western countries
and other states began to benefit from globalization, and above all, of
course, we are talking about the large states of Asia, the
West immediately changed or completely canceled
many rules about the sacred so
-called sacred principles of Free
trade, economic openness,
equal competition  even the right to
property was suddenly completely forgotten at once,
Western ideologists and politicians for
many years have been saying and repeating to the whole world of
democracy there is no alternative, the truth is
they were talking about Western liberal
so-called democrat models  and everything
else, all other options and forms of
democracy, they contemptuously and I want
to emphasize this through the lip arrogantly
rejected
such a manner that has developed for a long time since
colonial times, they consider everyone to be
second-class people, and they continue to be exceptional for
centuries until now